oh good look there's nothing like
rolling in an f-18 particularly when
you're doing it for science come on how
great is this job
NASA flies f-18s f-15s high altitude
former spy planes a 747 and even UAVs
all in the name of research people I
have to hire generally come from a
pretty diverse background always looking
for a broad breadth of experience
because I have a broad breadth of
airplanes that are here pilots at NASA's
Southern California Armstrong facility
are also responsible for flying the
agency's experimental aircraft which
over the decades have done everything
from break the sound barrier for the
first time to flying on electric power
there's a lot of training and even some
hanging around involved before anyone
gets into a cockpit to find out what it
takes to become a NASA pilot
I got a crash course from chief pilot
Nils Larsen first thing to do is reach
up and hit the button it says op all
right so now you're quiet good so that's
pretty good go ahead and do that roll or
half roll so that we're upside down
there you go stop it right about there
now pull straight back Neil's guided me
through NASA's f-18 simulator which is
about as close as you can get to
actually flying millions of dollars
worth of fighter jets without actually
fly no crashing I don't think we're
gonna survive that one so I guess you're
not recruiting me after all I was about
to ask you for a job yeah you know
everybody crashes on their first time Oh
nASA uses f-18s as chase planes when
flying experimental craft and for
research it's even used them for testing
gear headed to Mars we were working with
Jet Propulsion lab on the Mars Science
Lab as most people know this curiosity
and we helped do some of the testing of
the radar elements and we do little
pieces of the arre entry profile all the
way from just a few degrees nose low all
the way to going straight down everybody
was pretty excited about the project
because it was really important because
if you don't get this right you know
you're going to have a pretty expensive
hole in the side of Mars naturally
Neil's had me try a bit of it
hold the stick check it forward just a
little bit you can see now you're doing
about 60 degrees nose low as we're
plummeting at the ground I don't think
so
I don't think it's a game of nerves and
precision pull back so I'll recover nose
also show me the finer points of classic
roles as long as you're allowed to do
that or the science that you're doing if
you have an airplane that you can roll
you need to do it at least once a flight
of course it isn't all fun and aerial
maneuvers in the sim pilots have to be
ready for the worst possible situations
like ejecting from their plane to
prepare I went over to life-support to
get outfitted with a flight suit oh I
Topcon already look at an ejection seat
harness and a helmet what I can't hear a
thing in this helmet but apparently this
is most of what I need to be ready to
fight and by fly I mean being dangled in
a parachute simulator as you can see you
have a partial inversion so what you
want to do is scrap this side of the
larger lobe on all the risers and yank
yourself up on that side of the larger
lobe so it's like this side but has both
sides so right there with both hands go
ahead and reach over to your left side
my virtual parachute was all kinds of
fouled up but with a bit of guidance I
made it through to a safe landing so I
can see my parachute open back up
you have a full parachute son
down oh the girl so you want to put your
knees together feet together and point
your toes down and aim to fall on your
back rather than your front flying a
parachute isn't easy and takes stamina
skill guts landing posture okay
good have good abs for this which I
don't knees together ah collapse huh
that's actually holding my breath her
better I'm out of breath and I wasn't
even moving
but being ready to eject is just part of
the training
if you want to streak across the sky in
a fighter jet for science
[Music]